suis très contente patrick soit à une
actualité extrêmement chargé par acta
jamais été aussi heureux
non je suis heureux mais là tu peux pas
savoir la la la tournée du plus grand
cabaret c'est quelque chose de magique
tournée on est 100 sur la route il ya
cinquante artistes il ya un qui viennent
de partout qui viennent de du mexique on
est là en main trône à des danseurs
colombien ses danseurs jennifer lopez il
ya de tout il ya des ja fournée cette
recette semi remorque et on part pour 45
jours on finit le 31 décembre à genève
on va repasser par le palais des sports
par le dôme on y est et trois jours là
c'est c'est même au delà de ce que
j'imaginais sais tu peux pas savoir
qu'il faut aller bien et là c'est plus
des parts de marché ces peurs de plaisir
voilà
c'est un bonheur
voilà comme le brésil ça sort de la fête
ouais
les groupes
crédit
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est vrai que le petit bonhomme
en mousse envahie
j'aime
m
[Applaudissements]
les bulls m
trop
j'aime pas bonjour
m
et
[Applaudissements]
sur la grogne un maintien des chansons
la connaissance ont fait ou malaria
vivant il ya les pouces là les pousse la
salle
pour dire qu'on est heureux quand tu es
aussi bien depuis
les
joyeux celle appliquée
je suis au lit donc en gros
j'avais la danse des épaules et je
voulais faire une chorégraphié avec les
doigts donc on a des poux ce qui pousse
et le majeur il va préparer la
chorégraphie pour demander y a un majeur
merci l'album de patrick sébastien du
hard rock dossier on a six laquelle
c'est une chanson qui s'appelle
ça s'appelle la met la musique à fond ça
envoie grave à
la musique à fond bala m bala matin et
il ya le plus et l'alcool
[Musique]
ces matches on l'a fait et on a
également la bande annonce du lieu plus
grand cabaret en cabaret du monde tu
seras les 17 18 et 19 décembre au dôme
de paris et lampard demain on et
amnéville et puis strasbourg nancy dijon
là toute la semaine si tu pourrais
amener les chroniqueurs se demandent ils
sont invités d'ailleurs quand on repasse
au dôme
vous irez c'est magique je vous jure
d'apatrides ont fait pas chier merci à
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour ton livre date
j'adore aller dans tous les massifs et 4
ballons tout ils sont sages m battant
tous les sens rien et grimaud grands
mots croisés et divagations
réfléchissent offrir elle a lancé c'est
c'est un vrai lille ça c'est pas un
bouquin de mots croisés supplémentaires
il ya cinq ans de grille alors avec des
définitions j'essaie d'être
original motion élève de michel laclos
tu sais donc sur
michel a causé ce qui fait des mots
croisés dans le figaro est un maître en
matière de mots croisés donc je suis
verbicruciste c'est à dire je fabriquais
mots croisés et la halle à partir d'un
mot de chaque grille sur les 58 j'ai
fait des ce que j'appelle divagations
réfléchie des billets d'humeur comme
vous faites il cessa sur la société sûre
ça vraiment été rien c'est pour tous les
gens qui aiment les mots alors justement
nous on va faire un cyber seul croisés
je vous donne des anecdotes des
définitions des mots crâne est décédé
sur mon aile alors elle a fait sa
première partie à l'olympia
en cap m ouais c'est ça en 4h44 lettre
elle a fait sa première partie à
l'olympia commence pas maintenant
ballack ne boit pas là ici qu'est ce
qu'ils ont tous ils ont mis le nom et le
prénom ils ont mis le nom et le prénom
c'est la belle à un céline dion céline
dion très bonnes réponses elle avait 15
ans elle a été hyper stressée de monter
sur scène et qui la réconfortait s'est
pressée ong ça me fait drôle aujourd'hui
j'étais derrière le rideau en train de
me dire n'ai pas peur ma puce un glass
et c'était celle à une satire les plus
improbables de l'olympia patrick
sébastien en gros philippe lavil et ses
lignes au en tout petit
il afin d'abaisser saison est la même
seize ans c'est la fin mois tournait que
moi elle a dit dans sa biographie
d'ailleurs que c'était là qu'était
devenu adulte parce que c'était moi je
suis des imitations la ville chanter les
bambous et larrieu avec ses 36 de son
faux départ a été crohn et déjà sonné
avec rooney qui
a été elle travaillait avec la dde je
sais que c'est après ça s'est fait
pourquoi saison at il demandé une
dérogation c'est
aux présidents pompidou en deux
mariages c'est exactement il était trop
jeune pour le faire et vous avez demandé
et toi tu as voulu que ce soit moi et
j'ai demandé la permission au président
de la république par lettre j'avais 16
ans j'avais 16 ans puis c'était en
septembre et j'ai eu 17 ans en novembre
et je ferai en avoir 68 dans une
caste à l'italie avait demandé une
dérogation car pour mariage non non j'ai
pas mal à me marier directe ou indirecte
csc bull s'est mariée à 16 si j'étais
assez mariage
lui oui j'étais à l'école et quand ma
femme a accouché et salopards quand ma
femme a accouché j'étais au lycée je
suis rué en cours c'est fou de voir on
s'aime afin que vous viendrez quatre
heures de colle ni manger quand même
collé ces salopards je les appelais
à quel événement improbable la chanson
les sardines at-elle été joués regardez
alors la musique fait
quelques événements très bonnes
références en termes entièrement et
ouais on vous a même envoyé la vidéo
yann lachuer il ya la vidéo j'ai
d'ailleurs vu le fils de la dame c'est
une foraine qui voulait mais tu sais que
c'est fréquent je sais je sais je sais
que des gens qui ont beaucoup d'humour
qu'est-ce qu'on essaierait au fond de
cette boîte
il y a il ya tous les quinze jours je
reçois des vidéos de gens qui sont
enterrés que les serveurs et c'était un
truc de vacances à sa prime là dessus
c'est un métier qu'il a failli faire aux
44 qu'il appelle pas bien vocation de la
s'il fallait que je voulais trouver
attention eu affaire il ya pas longtemps
et policiers et ouais tu allais passer
le concours juste pour avoir un métier
et j'ai raté d'un point finalement été
la chance de ma vie
d'ailleurs je crois que je vais faire un
bouquin bientôt sur les les le mal qui
fait du bien tu sais le bal en moins
bien mais c'est un nom mais je suis
passé j'ai fait ça par vocation parce
qu'il fallait que je bouffe aller penche
pour une vue justement ma famille et
puis j'ai raté ça d'un coup il ya un
truc mais on sait qu'au bac j'avais eu
17 à l'oral et ni cette année créé en
france et au contour de flics j'ai eu
trois dont je me suis dit que c'était
pas le même français
avec 17 à l'oral 17 écrans français
ouais je vous la prof de lettres
combien pour ça que j'aime les mots
croisés triste moi j'ai pas été pas là
à l'oral qu'à l'écrit non quoique et
sérieux à l'oral qu'à l'écrit non mais
t'es bon français était très très bon
des notions et des notions aussi en
arabe tu sais en plus tu sais tu sais
tournée des phrases j'adore la plaisance
numérisés caractérisés directement en
sac un masque de quelle personnalité at
il offert à françois hollande
mais c'est après l'histoire du scooter
j'ai dit faut qu'il fasse un cadeau
génie pour pas que tu te fasses gaulle
et la prochaine fois je vais t'offrir un
masque de chat c'est drôle et je vais
amener ici à l'elysée je me suis dit van
m slim et il m'a dit je préfère pas
qu'ils reviennent vous avez été drôle il
a regardé le masque qu'il a fait tiens
qu'est-ce que c'est ressemblant le même
charisme et toupie la retourner il a
fait derrière c'est tout creux c'est
tout vide séduit
c'est la personne à qui vous envoyer un
crs pour se plaindre des bouchons
hidalgo a dit non non si
vous êtes comme au niveau de la
rigole et on était coincés ont été
coincés à la concorde c'est le président
chinois qui étaient là à ouidah et si
j'en avais plein le cul j'envoie un
message lui dit-on président chinois
commencent à nous casser les couilles et
immédiatement il a répondu oui mais va
nous les faire en or
la république et les bottes et enfin en
7 ou as tu déjà organisé des grands
gabarits allez les voir au bas des
grands gamins c'est quoi doit
co-organiser d'éviter spectacle visuel
non non non c'était pour les églises à
4,5 dernier anniversaire de chirac et ça
à mes frais exactement comme c'était un
grand gosse qui l'adoré tous ces numéros
je lui a mené 3-4 numéro 2 de cabaret
qu'on faisait il ya une chose quand même
extraordinaire les road tu sais qu'ils
montaient les aider à monter les trucs
etc et et à la fin aux déserts venez
manger avec nous venaient de l'est mais
qui ça revenait pas il les a invités les
techniciens venir manger le dessert avec
lui moi je sais pas qu'est ce que tu
aimerais bien fait au nom patrick
sébastien